[ __ ] it get off your high horse now bud
is it garbage to have a tattoo artist at
your wedding
holy [ __ ] yeah that's trash dude
yeah if you're in the Navy what the [ __ ]
holy [ __ ] you get married by a Hell's
Angel Jesus
holy [ __ ] did you get a tattoo on your
wedding day what was it
a wrench
I just love Snap-on Tools dude
yo check out my Nick Foles tattoo bro
did the misses get a tattoo yeah
what did you what did you get a drill or
something
a what
a monkey wrench
I'm not missing something I don't
[ __ ] hear them hey Pat you got a
wrench
and she got a monkey wrench
your first date was the Foo Fighters so
you've got Foo Fighters themed tattoos
on your wedding day nah that's real
classy dude
my bad you should you should have
elaborated beforehand that's the place
are you the mayor of happer oh what's
going on here
it's a good thing Limp Biscuit wasn't in
town that night
holy [ __ ] he's got a freight there's
tattoo on his chest what's up
I did it all for the nookie bro
that's beautiful shout out to the Foo
Fighters you're beautiful [ __ ] that
I'm not letting himself that's very
sweet pop it out for them guys one time
wait can I ask one follow-up please do
sir where'd you guys go on your
honeymoon
who was playing
I don't know if that makes sense all
right
could you just do like a cabin or go
skiing or something
okay okay
all right
sounds like you were dumping a body yeah
one more time clap it up 400 right
okay okay Philly
this one's from Jeff it just says have
you ever worn dress socks with Tims
that is a very specific feeling I know
whose wedding were you going to
and it was Patsy's
oh that's [ __ ] great all right let's
see uh this one
um is where's Sam C at
that might be
did you email
okay so that's probably you
Sam what's your full name Samantha
yeah it's [ __ ] True Detective over
here
hold on a second
are you Samantha by any chance
you're not Samuel are you does that
start with an S by any chance uh one
more thing
there you go older me got it
I thought you were asleep
yeah he just popped up there it's same
age older me somehow
wait what
we're both 36.
shut the [ __ ] up
I just want to feel your pulse hang on
holy [ __ ] he had a rough goal but didn't
you big boy
I'm sorry dude
you want something to eat or anything
like that okay
passion
where were we goodbye man
you guys you guys for sure are taking
the cake in the Philly show
all right oh Sam
[Music]